The Western is a classic film genre, so it's no
surprise that over the decades some have endured
to not only be great in its category, but among
the best movies ever. From old-timey classics to
violent Spaghetti Westerns, these are the only
near-perfect Westerns according to Metacritic.
Spaghetti Westerns reached new heights
with "The Good, the Bad and the Ugly,"
Sergio Leone's epic 1966 story of three
gunfighters on the trail of some Confederate gold.
Leone had pioneered Italy's run of stylish,
stark, yet grandiose Westerns with the great "A
Fistful of Dollars," which set up Clint Eastwood
as the Man with No Name, a lone and unpredictable
antihero who was good with a gun and always on the
move. In "The Good, the Bad and the Ugly," he's
back — and not even nicknaming him Blondie can
hide how dangerous he is. The tension runs high
as Blondie forms a wary partnership with bandit
Tuco to go after the gold. They might betray each
other ... or they might run afoul of the cruel,
capable Angel Eyes, who's also on the trail.
The result is a movie as hauntingly beautiful
as it is violent. It serves up both a mythic
American West and one that's stripped of all
the old-fashioned lore of good guys and their
white hats. It's a genre-defining film that
absolutely deserves its 90 on Metacritic.
Released in 2007, "No Country for Old Men"
has a 91 on Metacritic, and it definitely
deserves its place among the top-ranked
Westerns. The Coen brothers go especially
dark for this tale of stolen drug money,
violent times, and the forces of chance
and fate. The movie pulled in an incredible
Oscar haul, taking home statues for Best Picture,
Best Director, Best Supporting
Actor, and Best Adapted Screenplay.
The story is a film noir plot set in a Western
world. Llewelyn Moss is out hunting one day
when he stumbles on the grisly aftermath of
a shootout — and a briefcase full of cash.
He takes it ... and that decision
changes everything. Enter the terrifying,
off-kilter Anton Chigurh, a hired killer
who's supposed to retrieve the money and
who's so ruthless and violent in pursuit of it
that his own employers regret bringing him in.
"Nah I don't think that's how I'd describe him."
"How would you describe him?"
"I guess I'd say he doesn't
have a sense of humor."
Trying to make sense of it all is the
weary Ed Tom Bell, a sheriff who's seen
just about all he can stand but who will
have to see this horror all the same.
"No Country for Old Men" is bleak,
funny, and deeply memorable,
especially for its villain. With his
bowl haircut, air-pressure bolt gun,
and insistence on high-stakes coin
flips, Chigurh instantly became an icon.
If you missed "The Rider," there's never been
a better time to check it out — director Chloé
Zhao’s Oscar win for "Nomadland" gives you
a great excuse for revisiting her backlist.
And you'll have the benefit of hitting on one of
Metacritic's top Westerns, with a Metascore of 92.
"The Rider" is the story of Brady, whose life
on the pro rodeo circuit is cut short when an
accident leaves him with a brain injury that
causes seizures. He's not supposed to ride again.
A lot of movies would follow an inspirational
sports movie template and end with Brady back
at the height of his powers, but "The Rider" is
more restrained and realistic. Instead, we follow
Brady's struggle to adjust to falling back into
a life of limited options and even less glory.
Film critic Godfrey Cheshire notes that
the documentary-like realism is one of the
film's strengths. What you're seeing, from
horse-training to trauma to friendship, is
often real. Zhao handles all of this delicately,
with both empathy and respect. It's a vision of
the modern American West that's rooted in real
life and real people, and that makes it sing.
Clocking in on Metacritic with a score of
93, "Rio Bravo" isn't just one of the best
Westerns — it's one of the all-time great team-up
movies. It was director Howard Hawks' cinematic
rebuttal to "High Noon," which he thought made
its sheriff too wishy-washy and ineffective.
"Rio Bravo" has a laid-back, unhurried pace.
It has shootouts and action, but it's also a
classic hangout movie where a lot of the fun comes
from watching the low-key interaction between the
likable characters. One of the contrasts with
"High Noon" is that sense of friendliness.
Here, when trouble strikes and there's
going to be a raid on the local jail,
John Wayne's Sheriff John T. Chance rounds up a
team of motley allies. They might seem unqualified
or all washed-up, but he sees something in them.
And with charming performances from Dean Martin,
Ricky Nelson, Angie Dickinson, and Walter
Brennan, we see something in them too — fun.
John Ford's "Stagecoach," with a 93 on
Metacritic, has a simple and irresistible premise.
Take one stagecoach, fill it with a cast of
colorful characters, and put it in enough
danger that all the characters will have to
rise to the occasion in order to stay alive.
The result is a terrific movie, one that's
both exciting and emotionally involving.
It also provided John Wayne's breakout role
as the Ringo Kid, the heart-of-gold outlaw
whose gentle courtship of saloon girl Dallas is
one of the movie's highlights. And it cemented
John Ford as as a Western specialist, as
he'd go on to make other classics, making
]the film feels even more important. But it
doesn't need historical context to sell it. This
one's not a classic because of the role it played
in movie history. It's just that enjoyable.
"McCabe & Mrs. Miller" is Robert
Altman's version of the West:
and with a Metacritic score
of 93, it's a very good one.
Muddy and mumbly and morally ambiguous, with
its blend of brutality and poetry and its
sense of the tumultuous life of a whole town,
it feels like an ancestor of TV's "Deadwood."
The film offers wonderful performances from
Warren Beatty and Julie Christie as the two
title characters. They start out as business
partners in McCabe's brothel and eventually
drift into a kind of romance. But the love
story isn't necessarily a hopeful one,
and the boom in business doesn't keep them out
of trouble. None of this is destined to end well.
That nearly dreamlike quality is important because
Altman was reinventing how movies worked. While
parts of his unconventional approach, like the
way the dialogue is deliberately hard to make out,
might frustrate viewers, the
complexity here is rewarding.
"McCabe and Mrs. Miller" will linger in your
mind long after the credits have rolled.
With a Metascore of 94,
we have 1950's "The Gunfighter," which depicts
an age-old problem: When you're the best,
you're also the one everyone wants to beat.
Sooner or later, there's nowhere to go but down.
Gregory Peck plays Jimmy Ringo, famous as the
best gunfighter in the West. He's so famous,
in fact, that he always attracts trouble. There
are too many men looking to kill him and take up
his mantle. He's constantly having to fight for
his life — and when his challengers are dead,
their families sometimes show up seeking revenge.
All he wants, at this point, is to reconnect with
his estranged wife and finally meet his son, but
his reputation threatens to make it impossible.
The tension and tragedy of the movie work
together to give it an almost hypnotic pull.
Its look at the hollowness of celebrity
and the sorrow of a life spent on killing
once put the movie ahead of its time. Now
that approach makes the movie immortal.
"The Searchers" may not sit quite
at the top of Metacritic's list
but it still has a solid claim to
being the best Western ever made.
In 2008, the American Film Institute
honored it with that distinction,
and Sight & Sound went even further by declaring
it the seventh best film of all time, period.
It's easy to see why the movie attracts so many
admirers. The compelling story that follows John
Wayne's Ethan Edwards going after his kidnapped
niece, takes a heroic premise and twists it.
The result exposes all the brutality and racism
that can lie beneath the legends of the Old West.
Because the unsettling truth is that Ethan isn't
trying to save Debbie ... he only wants to kill
her so she won't have to live with having been,
quote, "despoiled" by her Comanche abductors.
That deep-seated anger and prejudice make
for one of Wayne's most complex performances.
"From now on you stay out of this -
all of ya! I don't want ya with me.
Don't need ya for what I gotta do."
Director John Ford portrays all this viscerally,
and accompanies it with some extraordinary
landscapes, giving "The Searchers" a
desolate but beautiful sense of place.
The combination makes for an
incredibly influential movie.
Harsh, striking, and powerful, this isn't
just a movie; It's a cultural landmark.
Even if you haven't seen "The Man Who Shot Liberty
Valance," you might know its most famous quote:
"This is the West sir. When the legend
becomes fact, print the legend."
The quote fits the movie, which is a classic
with a 94 on Metacritic. "The Man Who Shot
Liberty Valance" is all about how tall tales and
legends helped shape the Old West. It zooms in
on one story in particular — the intersection
of the fates of future senator Ransom Stoddard,
practical rancher Tom Doniphon,
and wicked outlaw Liberty Valance.
Valance terrorizes the town of Shinbone,
while Stoddard wants to bring it closer to
civilization and order. Tom stands somewhere
in between the two — his intentions are good,
but he lives by a violent code that
Stoddard can't approve of. Something
has to give ... and when it does, it will make
history. But will the history be the truth?
John Ford directed a number
of celebrated Westerns,
but "The Man Who Shot Liberty Valance"
as Roger Ebert points out is, quote,
"the most pensive and thoughtful." If you want
to see how lawless territories became lawful,
and what was won and lost in the
process, this is the film for you.
"The Wild Bunch" earned its Metascore of 97 by
drastically shaking up the Western template. This
1969 film pumped the genre full of controversial
and unprecedented levels of cynicism and violence,
giving us a Vietnam War-era look at all the
supposed cowboy heroes of times gone by.
The men in "The Wild Bunch" mostly live
sordid lives. They're vicious outlaws with
very little honor. They don't hesitate
to kill, and they're quick to use human
shields when they think it will help. Their
whole world is one of cruelty and violence,
but just before this unrelenting parade of
misery and cutthroat behavior becomes too much,
director Sam Peckinpah tosses in an actual
moral dilemma. One member of the gang is
kidnapped and tortured. Can the others bring
themselves to risk their lives for him?
While the movie certainly attracted
plenty of criticism for its viciousness,
time has definitely been on its side. In a
retrospective review, Rolling Stone said -
"The hard action, bracing wit, and mournful grace
of Peckinpah's cowboy classic shames every new
movie around. It's a towering achievement that
grows more riveting and resonant with the years."
The top-rated Western on Metacritic, with a score
of 98, "The Treasure of the Sierra Madre" is
famous for its grim, tragic portrayals of greed
in action. Humphrey Bogart plays Fred C. Dobbs,
a down-on-his-luck man whose health and sanity
unravel over the course of the film. That's what
can happen when you go prospecting - even when
you find gold, you tend to lose everything else.
"Badges? We ain't got no badges.
We don't need no badges. I don't have
to show you any stinking badges!"
Dobbs and his friends go out into the
Sierra Madre mountains to dig for gold.
The surroundings are inhospitable, the work
is exhausting, and the men are increasingly
paranoid. The tension is almost unbearable, and
Bogart vividly evokes Dobbs' fraying mental state.
It all leads up to a tragic, ironic twist
that even "The Twilight Zone" would envy.
The film still stands as one of the few
to have a perfect Rotten Tomatoes score,
and to sum it all up, Slant says -
"this deservingly canonized behemoth
is one of the relatively few films
that transcends the medium to become
a mandatory viewing experience for
anyone that identifies themselves
as a human being, period."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your
favorite film classics are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.